[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión haremos un
repaso del consumer electronic show el
famoso césped que en 2022 volvió con
toda la fuerza a la ciudad de Las Vegas
tras la pandemia de covid-19 iniciamos
hablando del exoesqueleto de German
bionic diseñado para todas las personas
que deben levantar objetos pesados se
llama cray ex y es la sexta versión de
este producto está equipado con
Inteligencia artificial por lo que va
aprendiendo Cómo se mueve quién lo usa y
permite cargar hasta 30 kilos con una
gran facilidad sin esfuerzos mayores en
la espalda
el producto es un exoesqueleto de
elevación activa que funciona con una
sola batería de 40 voltios esencialmente
lo que hace es que cuando te inclinas
reconoce tu posición relativa respecto
al suelo y cuando empiezas a levantarte
de nuevo detecta esos movimientos y a la
hacia arriba compensando unos 30 kilos
de fuerza de elevación pasamos ahora a
hablar del bote eléctrico con hidro alas
Que prácticamente vuela sobre el agua
fue desarrollado por la compañía sueca
Candela tiene 8,5 metros de largo
alcanza una velocidad de alrededor de 60
kilómetros por hora y puede recorrer
unos 92 kilómetros con una sola carga de
su batería
estamos a bordo del candela c8 y
contrario a los botes tradicionales que
golpean mucho las olas este vuela sobre
ellas un computador controla el vuelo
Así que es un viaje suave y nivelado en
casi todas las condiciones cuando esta
lancha alcanza los 30 kilómetros por
hora las hidroalas empiezan a funcionar
levantándola del agua y reduciendo la
fricción lo que hace que el consumo de
energía sea mucho más eficiente
el tercer producto del que vamos a
hablar fue presentado por el que fue
considerado el inventor de más edad en
esta feria tecnológica a los 83 años
Board filter creó Don't o no olvidar que
contiene dos prototipos el primero es un
dispositivo que se conecta al computador
de su automóvil y el segundo es un
detector de movimiento que se pone en la
puerta de su residencia el dispositivo
del automóvil detecta cuando el motor se
apaga y una voz grabada que se puede
personalizar le Recuerda que no olvide
lo que está dentro del vehículo ya sea
en unas llaves un celular una mascota o
un bebé porque caso se han visto Lo
mismo sucede con el sensor en la salida
de su casa
obviamente mientras investigaba por mi
experiencia para haber olvidado mi
teléfono celular descubrí que
literalmente en los últimos 20 años
alrededor de mil bebés han muerto por
insolación en autos porque los dejan en
los vehículos
mueren muchos y los perros aún más los
perros no sudan como los humanos jadean
y sudan por las patas por lo que son aún
más susceptibles
entonces creo que mi invento finalmente
salvará vidas el perro vive y el bebé
vive
vorta aseguró que busca inversores para
sus prototipos pero mientras tanto ya
lanzó una aplicación también llamada
don't forget que funciona como
recordatorio de voz para móviles está
disponible para Android y iOS es algo
que literalmente podría servirnos a
todos
pasamos a revisar el que fue presentado
como el primer Monitor de actividad
física que nunca se queda sin batería
esto porque se recarga con el sol y el
calor corporal se llama beheart Y fue
desarrollado por el laboratorio francés
de innovación baracuda
Tratamos de monitorear Los indicadores
de salud y la resiliencia mental esto
muestra el estrés acumulado del día
también monitoreamos la actividad las
calorías que se queman monitoreamos el
sueño la calidad y el tiempo también los
pasos y muchas otras cosas que se hacen
fuera de casa los datos son transmitidos
a dispositivos mediante una aplicación
que recopila toda la información el
costo del monitor que sale a la venta
esta Primavera estará rondando los 100
dólares
seguimos velozmente con otros dos
productos el primero es el whiting scan
un laboratorio portátil que se ubica en
El inodoro y que analiza muestras de
orina los datos envían al teléfono
mediante una aplicación y podría ser
extremadamente Útil para personas con
padecimientos renales crónicos el
segundo es una aplicación con
Inteligencia artificial llamada caresy
que con un video de 30 segundos del
rostro de una persona puede proporcionar
información sobre el ritmo cardíaco la
respiración y los niveles de estrés
vemos la sangre circulando por la piel
es un análisis de signos medimos la onda
más pura con un análisis directo de la
cara de la persona la respiración vemos
el pecho y contamos contamos el
movimiento
finalizamos con un divertido innovador
vehículo que fue presentado por BMW
estamos hablando de un coche Camaleón
que cambia de color con el ánimo del
conductor el prototipo se llama Vision d
y cuenta con una tecnología de tinta
electrónica que permite elegir 32
colores diferentes en 240 celdas
separadas que pueden cambiar de tono
individualmente para formar llamativos
patrones
la inspiración vino de la fascinación
por la tinta electrónica que ha estado
en los lectores electrónicos por años
esto es una capa que cambia de color al
reaccionar a Campos eléctricos y luego
quitas el campo eléctrico y el color se
mantiene ninguna luz hace eso así
llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a continuar con toda la
programación en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]